The Vatican Sistine Chapel in Rome is where cardinals meet in secret to choose a new pope.
Their election system varies depending on rules sometimes modified by the outgoing pope.
A two-thirds majority of cardinal votes is required to elect Benedict XVI's successor.
120 cardinals under the 80-year-old age limit...
...form the College of Cardinals taking part in the ballot.
Their deliberations traditionally begin between 15 and 20 days...
...after the previous pope's death or resignation.
When they enter the papal conclave, the cardinals must take an oath of secrecy...
...which, if broken, means automatic excommunication.
They remain there in total isolation until the new pope is chosen.
Two secret ballots are held each morning and each afternoon.
The papers are destroyed after each count.
As long as the two-thirds majority is not reached,...
...they're burnt with a substance giving off black smoke.
Once a new pope has been elected, white smoke is given off.
Having accepted and chosen the name he wishes to be known by...
...the appointment of the Pontifex Maximus, the Holy Roman Pontiff, is official.
The traditional announcement is then made from the balcony of St. Peter's Basilica,...
..."Habemus papam."
"We have a pope."